president Trump is back in Washington
where he is expected to continue a
shake-up of senior staffers and cabinet
members in the 14 months of his
presidency an unprecedented number more
than 20 top officials have already left
the administration that number is likely
to grow in the weeks ahead
National Security Adviser HR McMaster
Veterans Affairs Secretary David Shulkin
housing secretary ben Carson and chief
of staff John Kelly are considered most
at risk major Garrett is at the White
House with the newest information on the
staff and cabinet changes major good
morning
good morning the purge could take down a
chief of staff a national security
adviser and up to three cabinet
secretaries this is an unprecedented
situation even by the chaotic standards
of the Trump administration and to call
it a distraction would be an
understatement what ultimately happens
depends on president Trump's of volatile
mood and available willing replacements
we're coming back and doing it more so
than we've ever done before we're
setting records president Trump touted
what he called record-setting economic
progress in st. Louis Wednesday but the
turnover of top White House aides has
also made history so far more than 20
senior administration staffers have
either been fired resigned or reassigned
the next ago could be National Security
Adviser HR McMaster expected to be
replaced by former Bush administration
official and frequent Fox News analyst
John Bolton Bolton is a hawk on Iran and
North Korea like new Secretary of State
nominee Mike Pompeo a veteran secretary
David Shulkin could also be forced out
with Energy Secretary Rick Perry ready
to replace him in February the VA
Inspector General determined Shulkin
used taxpayer dollars on a lavish trip
to Europe for his wife mr. Trump joked
about firing Shulkin last summer it will
be properly implemented right David
better be David
we'll never have to use those words in
our David sources said Secretary of
Housing and Urban Development Ben Carson
is also in jeopardy after purchasing a
$31,000 dining-room set for his office
the order was eventually canceled and
the man brought in last summer to impose
order chief of staff John Kelly may also
be on the way out according to
congressional and administration sources
I don't like across-the-board tariffs at
president Trump's new chief economist to
CNBC commentator Larry Kudlow gave an
interview in which he disagreed with the
President on tariffs and NAFTA we
mustn't shoot ourselves in the foot
Kudlow who will replace Gary Cohn last
served in government in the 1980s he
asked Kohn himself a novice for a quick
refresher course I said Gary this is a
really dumb question but look what do
you do what's your day like what do you
do I made all of this there are
conflicting interpretations about the
job security of Attorney General Jeff
Sessions long a subject of president
Trump's scorn sessions could be replaced
by EPA Administrator Scott Pruett well
there are those I've talked to who
believe sessions may survive John simply
because a battle to confirm his
replacement would be too exhausting even
for this White House major thanks